Speaker 1: Some of you have been asking
me, Hey, David, sir, why haven't you been
showing us? Peter, do six questions during Jen
Psaki's press briefings because he's still asking
those attempted gotcha questions and he's failing.
And I'll be honest with you. The reason I haven't
been playing them for you is the questions have
gotten really boring and pedantic. I'm going
to play to kind of go through this exercise. I'm
going to play a couple of them for you today from
yesterday. But the back story on this is that from
day one, Fox News reporter Peter Dorsey's main
goal in the White House press briefing room has
been to try to use some kind of gotcha question to
either make Jen Psaki look bad or Joe Biden look
bad to then go on Fox News and have have everybody
give him a good old attaboy and say you did great
and have the Fox News audience titillated and and
excited about the questions that he's asking.
And there was one point where the questions were
so off the wall that they were actually funny,
entertaining, silly, whatever. They're so boring
now that I just haven't been playing them, and
I'll give you some examples and you guys tell me
whether you think this is something I should be
covering on the show. I understand I'm covering
it now, but we haven't talked about Doocy for
months and you're going to see why, because I
think that these are just such boring questions.
They don't really deserve our time. Let's take a
quick look at the first question from yesterday
Speaker 4: before Joe Biden was president. He
said that COVID travel restrictions
on foreign countries were hysterical
xenophobia and fear mongering. So what changed?
Speaker 3: Well, I would say first to put it
in full context, Peter, what
the president was critical of
was the way that the former president put out, I
believe, a xenophobic tweet and how he called what
he called the coronavirus and who he directed
it at. The president has not been critical of
travel restrictions. We have put those in place
ourselves. We put them in place ourselves in the
spring. But no, he does not believe he believes
we should follow the advice of health and medical
experts. That's exactly what he did and putting
in place these restrictions over the weekend.
Speaker 1: Now, I think that the better topic
is and I already broached this, there's a really
good topic here, OK? This thing about Biden saying
travel bans are xenophobic and the counter being
No, no, no. He said the way Trump was talking
about the China virus and China is xenophobic, but
travel bans themselves are not. It's so boring.
The real question is South Africa did a good thing
by sequencing the new Omicron variant. Joe Biden
is calling it omni chron, but it is Omicron,
the Omicron variant alerting the world
to it. By the time we learned about it,
it was we knew it was already in a handful of
other countries. I think it was like Belgium,
Hong Kong, Netherlands. It's been found in Canada,
OK? And then as a result of learning about this
from South Africa, a travel ban was placed
by a number European Union U.S. other
on countries from southern Africa, including South
Africa and other countries down there. And so the
real question here is are we punishing a region
of the world, not South Africa specifically,
but some of those other countries in southern
Africa that are not wealthy countries
because they did the right thing and they told
us what's going on when it's already spread,
the cat is already out of the bag. Does that
really make sense? And everything I'm reading
from public health experts is the travel bans
at this point don't really make sense. You got
to keep testing, you've got to do whatever
else, but it's everywhere. At this point,
it doesn't really make too much more sense
to block travel from some of those countries
than some other countries that don't have any
travel. That's like a good topic. He wants to
go. What about Joe Biden in saying xenophobia?
And then also here going with a question about
Joe Biden not wearing a mask in a store.
Speaker 4: He was shopping in a store and
on the glass outside. It said
face coverings required. And we
could see him inside and his face was uncovered.
Speaker 3: Well, again, Peter, our recommendation
and advice continues to be for people to wear
masks when they are required in establishments.
I don't know what this establishment was.
The president obviously follows the health,
the advice of his health and medical team.
Speaker 4: Is there a concern that when the
president says today, please wear your
mask indoors in public settings around
other people and he doesn't do that, that it's
going to make it harder to get people to follow?
Speaker 3: I think you see the American people
and all of you see the president wearing
a mask every time he comes out to an event.
Speaker 1: So you guys get the picture. I mean,
listen, does it? Does it look not great for
if Biden saying you got to wear masks inside?
And then he goes into a business and he doesn't
wear a mask? Is that does that hurt his his
argument? It probably does to some degree. But the
people that are not wearing masks are already not
wearing masks. They're not going to say, Oh, Biden
was photographed without a mask. So in that sense,
it's another one of these. Waste of a
question wanting to create a sound bite,
so listen, that's why I've not been covering
the Ducie questions, because they're boring.
They're kind of pointless and they're very
pedantic. But if you guys want more coverage
of the Ducie questions, let me know and
you can let us know. We'll be posting this
clip to our Instagram at David Pakman show.
You can let us know there in the comments.